i was driving
in a car um with it with a young woman
at the beginning of the dream she seemed
to be
a particular person i i i know who
in fact a student former student of mine
and the the central part of the dream
involved an episode where i could look
out through the top of the car
it was at night and see the whole dome
of the sky very vividly
and the stars seem to be extremely close
i could see them not as points of light
but but as spheres as solid spheres
and i could make out all kinds of
details such as the the rings on planets
like saturn and jupiter which one
wouldn't normally see
even even in the dream itself i remember
being very
very struck by this very impressed by
this
i remember remarking to my companion
that it would be a beautiful night for
going for a walk
this dream begins i'm driving by night
with a female companion
it is therefore he is not at home he is
not in his professional situation at the
university
he is not milling around in a pub with
other people
he is driving at night with a female
companion
and there you one could then ask him
how does one feel in such a situation
that's a situation
where one relaxes where one thing
where one puts aside
the ones daily worries one is open
to nature to one is open to
seeing something new or
depends on the relationship to the
feminine companion
what else one has in mind
but it suggests also a rather possibly a
love situation of at least a situation
of positive companionship
in contrast to intellectual effort or
social
amusement or so on and it is night
then we we have to say what ask
ourselves what is it
in the night again in the night we are
inclined to be
more open more romantic
more reflective because our attention is
not
drawn away by telephones and outer
things
it is a moment of
relaxed reflection
in general where also the feeling
and the repressed other sides of the
personality come up
and now they look he looks up to the
sky the sky is
has always been one of the most
fascinating sights for mankind
and if we go into the history of mankind
the stars have always been divine
figures gods even the bushmen in the
kalahari desert
see in every star constellation the
great hunter or the great
god in each constellation and the stars
is the realm where
according to myth week our soul comes
from
and where it returns after death in the
stars and
if you think of the history of astrology
and astrology has been
spread not only in the west but also in
india china and everywhere
in all high civilizations we have
astrological
traditions there the stars always served
to to prognosticate the future to find
out
the future not only of a person but of
mankind
in china a whole
group of astrolog astrologers had to
watch the sky day and night
and report to the emperor all signs in
the sky
which were interpreted as
relating to the fate of the chinese
empire
and in a similar way in antiquity
everything was
seen in the sky do you feel that the
destiny of individuals and societies
is related to the constellation in the
stars
the constellations in the sky represent
the background constellations of great
historical events
as if in our deeper unconscious we are
not
isolated we are linked up with the whole
of mankind
we are and and mankind is dreaming a
dream along
which amounts for the changes in
politics and religion and everything if
you think only how much
the outlook of mankind has changed in
the last 30 years you see how
such big collective changes take place
and to look at the sky could therefore
be seen he's looking at the deeper
constellations constellations comes from
the word stellar star
the togetherness of stars
the deeper constellations of collective
and of his own personal life
why does the dreamer try to find the
constellation in the stars
he needs an orientation where am i in
this time what is my task
and so he looks up to the sky and sees
especially this combination of jupiter
and saturn
now saturn as he's well known he's an
evil doer
scorpion serpents the donkey and so on
belong to his realm
he is a dark destructive
spirit and jupiter is in general the
star of the kings of the king of justice
of worldly expansion
of a royal personality of magnanimity
and all the positive qualities of a
royal personality
so what the dream tells the dreamer is
that when he looks for the constellation
of
time and naturally also of his own life
there is a combination of extreme
opposites
it's a moment of change of where
destructive and constructive forces
are constellated simultaneously
he he's only first in the first part of
the dream
only impressed by the beauty
of the nocturnal scene and proposes to
go for a walk leave the car and go for a
walk
this is a big step forward he gives up
the mechanical way of moving through
life
and when you walk you are in much closer
touch
with nature but you are also very much
slowed down
so you go step by step
and you feel the country you feel the
earth you feel the trees in the air
around
you much better so that is the positive
change which
comes around from this vision
on the sky